>> Tucker: EVER NOTICE HOW
WHEN YOU CRITICIZE A WHITE
LIBERAL, THEY CALL YOU RACIST.
NO I'M CRITICIZING YOU, THE
WHITE LIBERAL, RACIST!
IT'S HILARIOUS!
BUT IT'S THEIR FIRST AND LAST
OFFENSE, HIDING BEHIND OTHER
PEOPLE OF OTHER ETHNICITIES TO
PUSH THROUGH THEIR PREFERRED
POLICIES.
ON NO SUBJECT IS THIS MORE
OBVIOUS THAN IMMIGRATION.
FOR YEARS, JOURNALISTS TOLD US
HISPANIC VOTERS LOVE OPEN
BORDERS.
IF YOU DON'T, YOU'RE A RACIST.
ALL OF A SUDDEN, THERE IS
COGNITIVE DISSONANCE GOING ON
BECAUSE HISPANIC VOTERS ACTUALLY
DON'T SEEM TO LOVE OPEN BORDERS
AND THAT'S WHY IN HISPANIC
DISTRICTS YOU'RE SEEING
REPUBLICANS GETTING ELECTED.
EXTREMELY UPSET ABOUT THIS THEY
ARE TRYING TO FIGURE OUT WHAT
HAPPENS.
THESE VOTERS AREN'T AS OBEDIENT
AS THEY THOUGHT THEY WOULD BE,
THEY DON'T HAVE THE SAME
ATTITUDES IN WILLIAMSBURG.
WHAT THE HECK!
THEY PUBLISHED AN ARTICLE WITH
THE HEADLINE "THE RISE OF THE
FAR RIGHT LATINA," THAT'S OUR
KIND OF GUEST.
ONE OF THOSE THEY REFERRED TO IS
CASSIE GARCIA WHO IS RUNNING FOR
CONGRESS IN TEXAS AND GRATEFUL
SHE'S JOINING US TONIGHT.
CASSIE GARCIA, I DON'T KNOW WHAT
A FAR RIGHT LATINA IS BUT IT'S A
BADGE OF HONOR AT
"THE NEW YORK TIMES" DOESN'T
LIKE YOU AND WERE GLAD TO HAVE
YOU.
IF THEY ARE ATTACKING YOU
BECAUSE YOU DON'T HAVE THEIR
VIEWS?
IS NOT WHAT'S HAPPENING?
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME ON.
IT'S RIDICULOUS, THE FACT THAT
THE VULNERABLE MEDIA WOULD CALL
ME A FAR RIGHT LATINA BECAUSE I
GREW UP IN A CONSERVATIVE
HOUSEHOLD ON THE BORDER AND THEY
WENT TO CHURCH IS ABSOLUTELY
RIDICULOUS.
YET THEY PRAISE AOC AND THE
SQUAD IT.
LET TELL YOU, THEY DON'T
REPRESENT THE VALLEYS IN SOUTH
TEXAS AND THE REASON WHY AM
RUNNING FOR CONGRESS IS STIFF TO
FEND FAITH, FAMILY, FREEDOM.
FOR OVER A 110 YEARS, THE
INCUMBENT HENRY WHO SAYS ALL THE
RIGHT THINGS HAS DONE ABSOLUTELY
NOTHING TO SECURE THE SOUTHERN
BORDER AND IN FACT I'VE RECEIVED
OF THE ENDORSEMENTS OF THE
NATIONAL BORDER PATROL COUNCIL
WHOSE ENDORSED HENRY BUT THEY
ENDORSED ME IN THE RACE.
>> Tucker: DO YOU THINK IT'S
WEIRD THAT SOME -- WHITE LIBERAL
FROM THE UPPER LEFT SIDE WHO
WENT TO BROWN AND SENDS HIS KIDS
TO RIVERDALE COUNTRY SCHOOL GETS
TO SPEAK FOR HISPANIC VOTERS ON
THE MEXICAN BORDER IN TEXAS?
WHERE DID THEY GET THE RIGHT TO
DECIDE WHAT YOU ARE ALLOWED TO
BELIEVE?
>> I'M RESENTING THE FAMILIES
THAT COMMUTE IN DISTRICT 28TH,
IF THEY DON'T SPEAK FOR ME, THE
NEW YORK PARTY LEFT OF THE
HISPANIC COMMUNITY AND WE CARE
ABOUT A STRONG AND SECURE
BORDER.
IF WE DON'T WANT OPEN BORDERS AT
ALL, AND THAT'S WHAT THE
DEMOCRATIC PARTY BELIEVES IN AND
WE DON'T BELIEVE IN THAT.
WE BELIEVE IN SOVEREIGN BORDERS,
AND SO THAT'S WHY WE ARE GOING
TO SEE MORE DEMOCRATS VOTE
REPUBLICAN COME NOVEMBER.
WE WILL SEE MORE DEMOCRATS WALK
AWAY.
>> Tucker: YOU'RE OBVIOUSLY AN
AMERICAN BUT IMMIGRANTS WHO JUST
GOT HERE OF ANY BACKGROUND DON'T
WANT OPEN BORDERS AND WHY WOULD
YOU WANT TO COME TO A COUNTRY
THAT'S NOT A COUNTRY OF COU